All right, let's see what is on the minds
of folks in the audience. Don't worry, I'm
not taking phone calls right now. I know that
that would be the absolute worst nightmare
for many in the audience. We're not, it's
Thursday. We're not taking phone calls. Phone
calls will be tomorrow. You don't have to
turn off the show. I am talking about the
David Pakman show subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash R E. D. D. I. T. a few posts that came
to my attention. A lot of people ask me about
this. Eric Weinstein recently tweeted about
the left. I think the left has reached a hard
fork.
Those that want to explore extreme wokeness,
open borders, anti whiteness, apologizing
to homophobic, misogynist, theocracies worlds
without men, reparations for slavery, cancel
culture, et cetera. Need to branch off and
good luck. You'll need it. Listen, here's
my view about this is there I, I wouldn't
call the left having, I don't believe the
left has reached a hard fork. I think that
on the highway of the left, it's not even
an off ramp. It's like one of those driveways
that usually says for authorized vehicles
only that aren't really supposed to turn off
of. It's not actually an exit. It's not the
highway splitting and there are some people
on the left who are going in that direction.
I maintain that, um, that group is smaller
than many make it out to be and disproportionately
loud, particularly on the internet. But again,
in the same way that those of us in internet
culture don't understand where are all these
Biden's supporters.
But then when you go into the real world,
you see there's lots of people that you just
don't really hear from, uh, in the online
political mill. You who support Joe Biden,
that's a reality. It's not an endorsement.
He's not my guy. I'm just telling you, Joe
Biden does have more support than you would
glean from being online. This wing of the
left, this sliver of the left, as I call it,
has less support than you might believe if
you spend a lot of time on Twitter and on
Reddit. So I, I don't agree with Eric Weinstein
that it's a hard fork, but I've pointed out
that there are people on the left who, uh,
who share the priorities that he's listing
there another post, uh, about my hair. And
we're actually going to talk about this a
little bit later. I knew David's hair was
reminding me of someone, please reassess head
symmetry and hair goals in 2020.
Uh, God bless. Sorry for the S post and there
is a picture of Gumby. Yeah, there, there
have been some technical issues we've been
experiencing with my hair over the last few
days and I'm actually going to talk about
it, uh, on tomorrow's program, so I don't
want to short circuit that conversation now.
And lastly, there was a shirtless picture
of me that went up on my Instagram a couple
of years ago. I think it was me jumping into
a pool in Northwestern Spain, uh, or in, in
Spain, not in Northwestern Spain. And there
are more and more calls for that opposed that
says it's been almost two years since shirtless.
Pacman pics have surfaced. David should post
more shirtless pics on Instagram for the people.
Yeah, it's a not happening anytime soon, but
sometimes, incidentally, there will be a picture
very, very zoomed out where I am, uh, maybe,
maybe shirtless.
Um, join the discussion. I suggest participating
in the one about the hard fork on the left
rather than about my hair or shirtless pictures@davidpakman.com
slash R. E. D. D. I. T